i will turn it over to you chris well
thank you very much
i will share
hide that can everybody see everything
okay
looks perfect looks good great um so yes
thanks again
for our studio for hosting this i think
it's really exciting that we can kind of
get together as a healthcare community
um and start to share some of the work
we're doing
with our and with shiny and some of the
things that
we'll see today i hopefully can spark
some conversation
going forward among all of us
oops let's see sorry
there we go um so just a little
background on children's
children's wisconsin has been around for
about 125 years a little bit more we had
our anniversary a few years ago
it was originally founded just by seven
philanthropic philanthropists
in milwaukee who just they rented a
house and it
had 10 beds and it was just very humble
beginnings
and then throughout the 125 years that
we've grown and grown we've had a couple
moves we were on
a building on marquette university's
campus for a while
and now we've moved to the medical
milwaukee regional medical center mrmc
which is in the background of this slide
and there we are also joined by
froedtert healthcare it's an adult
system
as well as the medical college of
wisconsin so children's is a learning
hospital
and so it their attitude i think really
helps foster a lot of the innovation
that
we get to explore using r and shiny
currently and so we're definitely well
supported and
curiosity and innovation are two of our
core values
so hopefully that'll shine through today
as i start to
show you some of the things we're
working on
um as such we get to uh you know we get
to work with everybody across the system
and so i think this is one of my
favorite
quotes um john tukey not only gave us
box plots he gave us this good quote
where
as a statistician or a data scientist or
an analyst
we get to work with in all different
areas things you would never expect in
other
disciplines i think children's
lets us especially as part of the
enterprise analytics team that my data
science program is part of
we get to work with quite a few
different people across the system
and you can see children's is really
more than just a hospital for
acute things or chronic conditions we do
have two hospitals we have a level one
trauma center
in emergency department but we also do
research with the medical college
um children's social service society of
wisconsin
came under the children's wisconsin
umbrella in 2004
so we also have a foster care and
and child and family well-being and
that's part of what i'm going to show
today was one of the projects that i
worked on with
regard to youth placed in group homes
we also have primary care specialty care
clinics we have interesting programs
with school nurses where we put
our nurses will be in milwaukee public
schools to make sure kids are getting
the care they need
when we can get that when we can have
access to them and then we also have a
health plan so we actually
um have a a part of children's that
actually
provides a health plan and makes sure
kids are covered and get
the preventative care that they need
so it really is more than just a
hospital and this gives us all the
different
backyards to kind of play in so it's
kind of an exciting thing
as this slide just gives a quick
background we have over 90 locations
all generating tons of data that we try
and collect as best we can in our
enterprise data warehouse so we do have
quite an impact on the state of
wisconsin and especially for kids
because that we know that they're unique
you know you can't put a kid in an adult
sized bed
you know they have different different
needs and so we really try and cater to
that
[Music]
so i thought i would jump in and give a
kind of a quick
uh example of um some of the work we've
done with
r and shiny and then kind of come back
around and say well how did we get here
because this certainly isn't
the first thing we we attempted to do in
our and we kind of grew
our our practice as we went along it's
definitely been probably a
seven or eight year um journey
as as it's people commonly say for us to
kind of get to this point where we
actually are can
rapidly deliver some really interesting
insights using iron shiny
um so the missing and missing ohc uses
out of home care
youth these are our youth who are
generally placed
are removed from their homes in some
kind of dangerous situation maybe
there's safety concerns maybe there's
something going on in the house that
isn't safe and they've been have case
managers assigned to then we place them
the best we can either in foster care or
in sometimes group homes
so this project originally kicked off
where we were trying to understand
um youth who are leaving that placements
when they go missing
so these youth are generally 12 to 18
years old
they're active in the community they
have friends across the community
and they um go missing and we're
responsible for them
but yet we don't know where they are and
so that's not a good situation to be in
of course
um so as we started to work with our
social services partners we
looked at reasons why kids
would go missing but we kind of put a
twist on it and we started to look at
reasons why they stay the ones who
stayed why are they staying
we were trying to do some analysis with
respect to that
our case management team serves about
1200 youth
annually and that's just in milwaukee
county
milwaukee county is a very unique area
in that the county itself doesn't handle
the case management services there's two
organizations contracted and children's
is one of those
to provide that so we each get about
half of those kids
and then we also look for permanency of
course for these kids as we're um
placing them in these these homes and
but hopefully it's in a safer
situation which is what we're going
after
so what does it really mean to be
missing
it's anyone younger than 18 it's the
federal law right
like they're unknown to their legal
guardian for dcf department of child and
family for the state of wisconsin
it's if they're missing more than eight
hours and we don't know where they are
we um it has to be reported the good
thing for us then is that gets recorded
in the state's
um child welfare information system the
sackvists
and so we can then actually use that
data to try and understand
when they went missing we know kids
where they're staying
for both um both our agency and the
other agency that's managing care in
care in this county and then we can
actually kind of have rosters of kids so
we know who was staying together at a
time who went missing at the same time
and we can build out timelines
and so that's part of the interesting
work that you'll see here in a second
what you'll notice here in this plot is
sometimes there can be up to 40 kids who
are
are missing um and so that's quite a bit
right we're going oh my gosh we have
there's 40 kids that we're responsible
for as an organization we don't know
where they are
we need we they really needed to um have
us be involved to help understand what
the
what the trends were because it's been
increasing
so as a good good statistician a good
data scientist the first thing we did
was we tried to look at some of the
factors that were involved
this here is an example of a survival
analysis we did
of looking at if the if a child is
placed into a family setting either
with a relative or in a foster home
where it's
a smaller setting not a group home they
have a much more success
in not going missing as well as
staying in that setting for longer a
longer period of time
once we found these kind of interesting
factors that got us
some credibility to keep working on this
problem and it certainly led to more
questions
as we went along and so the the extra
questions that we had
there were there were too many and it
was too dynamic right we were kind of
going well what if this what
what's going to happen if you know
someone does go missing how many are
going missing where are they leaving
or you know going missing from and where
were they
possibly removed from to where they were
placed and so we started to think about
well what could we do to answer these
questions in a more dynamic fashion
and that's where shiny came in for sure
so this is a screenshot of the
application i'm going to
run through and give you a quick
demo of one of our applications so it's
called
um
sorry about that um so this is um called
that we called it the missing
out of home care youth explorer and so
we really were trying to explore this
population of kids
who have been removed and then placed
under our care
and so we pulled the information from
our state's
child welfare system which is that
sacrifice i mentioned
we also pulled a bunch of other data
together
from the census bureau and understanding
the environment we're placing the kids
into
and then we started to think of ways to
visualize that
so i can just from this dashboard view
we gave a quick view of the kids who are
missing so people these
case managers will use this application
now to look at kids
and i should mention before i um go any
further that this is all anonymized data
so
everything you're seeing here we've
truncated some of the data and we've
anonymized names so none of this is
um real real children it represents the
same relationships though underneath
um so these um these are the kids like
who would be currently missing so they
can look on a dashboard we can also look
at placement providers who maybe are
having a lot of kids go missing from
maybe those aren't the
right places for us to be putting kids
who are we deem at risk
and at risk means maybe they aren't a
known
trafficker in this case a lot of the
times we're looking at kids who maybe
are involved in human trafficking
if you've seen the news and heard about
jeffrey epstein you know
trafficking is is rampant to milwaukee
is one of the
areas that it really has had a big
impact
so we actually start to look at where
can we safely place kids that maybe
aren't as risky of a situation if
there's someone else there as a known
trafficker we don't want to put someone
who is
younger possibly or maybe potentially at
risk of being trafficked
um i'm gonna jump then to the next so
the first thing we thought of is well
why don't we look at look uh kids when
they're placed together so co-locations
so we know when kids are together and
then we know when they go missing
so let's look at like a social network
of this and so let's try and build out
what it might mean for these kids to be
missing um
and when they leave together how does
that visualize
um so if you look here this is using um
igraph and viz network if you know some
of the packages that are involved
and it's an interactive graph then of
all the kids and the relationships
when have they been placed together
thicker lines mean that
they've been placed co-located together
more often so if i highlight a line for
instance
you'll see that there's been nine
co-locations between tashika
and rialta and then the bigger the dots
mean that they have more connections in
the network
and this is just the network of kids who
are either currently missing
or um are related one step away from
someone missing like if we looked at the
overall network of placements
you'll see it's much busier it's like
this is just a big web right of
of movement but what we're really
interested right now is in these kids
who have gone missing
and trying to investigate so if i come
back here and take a look at
um some of the kids
i'm going to click on one right here so
i picked clicked
on a name and so you can see i get
information about them
we started to create a score of
influential kids in the network
and so i clicked on a blue link and this
is someone who's at risk of being
trafficked
they also have a lot of connections in
this in this network
so it gives us an ability to kind of
score them and say yeah there's some
risk here
let's take a look we haven't done a lot
of work with the scoring profiles yet
that is something that is a future
ask for us but what i can do then is if
i we pick
someone interesting in the network we
can actually go look at their individual
network
so this is regardless if missing or not
or how many steps away this is all the
people they've ever been
placed with or associated with and
um you'll see again i can kind of zoom
in
oops and then if i um look at the color
coding of this network
suspected means that we actually have
had someone a case manager
and we have liaisons with law
enforcement we somehow have tagged them
as
it's suspected that they're involved in
trafficking
um so again we can like look at that
like if i click on a person here like
magaly nibs or if we click
um you can click away here and click on
another one
you'll see it'll change here anna lee
modi
so they'll have their information of
where they're currently placed
and if someone goes missing that might
be a person that we might want to reach
out to we might want to investigate
where is anna lee
and so we can also add her so if she's
suspected
of trafficking we can add her to this
network and now you'll see we'll start
to get a picture
of how do they know each other how have
they been placed together
yeah whenever they place together we can
actually look at timeline views as well
of this and so these are some of the
people they know together so if someone
is missing and then
like enid was is there someone else
missing in this
group and this might be a reason why
they've gone missing or maybe we could
help find find people and now you can
also see
you're starting to get some of the red
dots and these are confirmed traffickers
who we're still responsible for
they're placed in a group home in the
city right now
and you can see they're one two three
steps away as far as relationships go so
definitely could be some
trafficking involved so this is
uh one view i guess of what we had done
to understand what's going on and to be
helping the case managers
in making better placements you may not
want to place someone who's at risk if
there's a
a confirmed trafficker at a location and
you have choices of where to put them in
a group home for instance
different group homes you could place
them in a different
location so it's really helping to
inform that case management and
placement services
our second view then so that was one
view as a social network
if we look at it from a different
perspective we could also think about it
from a geographic perspective and this
is where we're thinking about
where are kids getting placed and where
have they been removed from where are
their support structures
as we're starting to think about um
placing kids in safe places
but also in places that they still have
friends i mean
you can't just take them out of their
environment plunk them down somewhere
else and expect them
to be successful put them in a new
school
so as we collaborate with the social
workers and the case managers
they help us to understand that there
there are some effects that maybe we
could help inform them again
of where the best places are and to
place
these kids so i'm going to grab so i'm
here we're using leaflet and i'll kind
of do a recap at the end of all the
technology behind this
but we're using leaflets leaflet markers
and marker groups to kind of hold
together all the placement providers so
this is a list of all the placement
providers
in the city so this is milwaukee you can
see there's kind of a geo fence around
the different markers
of where these uh placement providers
are
if i scroll in or zoom in here a little
more
we'll start to get a look at the city
and then you can kind of see milwaukee
is
kind of bisected by uh east-west freeway
i-94 is right here
so we can kind of see north of 94
there's a lot more placement providers
and these either as we scroll and you'll
see it's color-coded markers
they're either a foster home maybe a
relative
or a group home as we get to some of the
green dots you'll see these become like
these are group homes that are in the
city
the names are changed but the these are
actually
different group homes across the city
and we can track
who is there right now if they've ever
had a trafficker
and those pop-up bubbles on the markers
will explain that
so now we can start to get a good look
at the city and one thing
the case management noticed right away
is how many more
placement providers are to the north of
the of i-94
versus the south um in a second i can
show you the removal map
and you can see we remove equally from
both sides of
the highway but it seems like there's
more um placement
providers being licensed more group
homes being licensed to the north of the
city
so we're taking kids out of the south
side and putting them on the north side
and then they're going to go missing and
it's just this
this kind of circular events that we
know is going to happen so now we're
trying to think about how we can
creatively put more of those group homes
to the south side if neighborhoods can
approve them
certainly one thing
[Music]
we did so we first we started thinking
okay geographic replacement then we
started to think about what other
factors are involved
what's important to know um so we
actually brought in
data from the gun violence archive and
because milwaukee also has
you know many people do is violence gun
violence is a big issue
today we brought in gun violence and we
can actually
um blade the gun violence events on top
of this
so this is the gun violence for the last
six months on uh the map and here you
can see
we're putting these group homes right
into such a dangerous area right all the
group homes that these kids are being
placed at are going into the same area
of the city
where a lot of our gun violence is
occurring so
this is also very informative because we
do have
people who advocate for us at the state
and federal level
showing information like this is very
helpful
to us for advocate for my advocacy
perspective perspective
okay if i ask a few of the questions
then oh absolutely
i'm yes because you were just mentioning
the data that you bring in as well sep
had asked the question how is all the
data collected
clean and stored and retrieved that
fuels this great work
um yeah that's that's a great question
so um certainly the
the data science team is is a small team
we don't have a ton of data scientists
we sit within the analytics group
and so we actually have um data
engineers on the
in the analytics team who get shared and
so we use them to actually bring in a
lot of this data and we store it we have
a data warehouse that it gets stored in
and then we pull that what we need into
like in our data file for shiny to use
but
we the data engineers do that cleaning
and scrubbing and bringing the data
together
for us we kind of collaborate with them
i think the data scientists a lot of
times we'll take that first pass
and just take a rough cut of the data
think about what we need and look for
quality issues and distributional issues
um and then they'll they'll automate
that and productionalize it
thank you and just a ton of people
saying what an incredible use case
really so powerful the work that you're
showing us and
oh thank you thank you yeah
i'll just ask two other questions here
just to take a little
break in between so we don't save them
all for the end but jake
asks what are you using to link igraph
to the selected youth info
panel is that crosstalk or something
else
um i i don't know if i follow that
question
so can i see that in the chat or is that
so linking i think linking that um
like info panel over to the right and
jake
feel free to jump in here and and add
any other context
yeah when when you click on a point it
then populates that info chart
yes you were like doing the selected
point
and having training so crosstalk is a
package that will help
link widgets together but i was curious
how you're getting
i think i'm we're capturing i would have
to look at the code
because this is um i should have said at
the beginning this is something i worked
on it two years ago this is one of our
first shiny apps
but i believe i'm just capturing the
point and then i'm i'm popping it up i
don't think i even use crosstalk you can
there's events that come off of that eye
graph off this network
and i believe i'm capturing that and
then looking at the
the panel but i could follow up with you
after for sure to show you what i did
or talk about it thanks
yeah thanks chris one other question
just briefly i know you mentioned these
are all anonymous
uh names now or anonymize
is that package available externally
that is actually something that i i
created in for this it's something that
we could probably
think about how we would get that out
onto public into github but for right
now it's that switch at the beginning
and stuff is something i created
and i do pull names i think i was
telling rachel yesterday we pull names
from the census bureau and just
anonymize
male female and yeah
awesome thanks chris yeah
um yep so in the interest of time i'll
um
just skip ahead a little bit so you've
seen the maps and we did
on top of this we also started to look
at how we could maybe show
depict the city in different ways and so
this is where we were talking about
using census data and american community
survey data
the neighborhood stress model it's a
scoring model
that looks at stressful areas the city
it was developed at the university of
massachusetts
this was the first use case we did of
this
and it actually proved very useful so it
was interesting again to see
where we're where we have our homes our
group homes and our foster homes mostly
placed
are in very stressful areas of the city
and what does it mean to be stressful if
you look at this it looks at poverty it
looks at
unemployment public assistance and then
education factors
from the community survey and the census
and then we lay that back on that
that map then for them again to
understand as we start to license more
group homes and foster homes
we maybe don't want to always put them
in the stressful areas of the city right
that's like
i think this was an interesting way to
illuminate that and this is down to the
um
census tract level so that's why you're
seeing it kind of
very granular so it's interesting look
at kind of that
that same parts of the city and just in
a different way
um without having to just say income or
race and kind of show those standard
things that we always see on a map the
stress score was a very interesting one
so we've run that stress score now and
that's part of our
ongoing modeling every year when the acs
gets updated in december we rerun the
stress scores for the city and then we
use this in multiple apps and analyses
um as we go as we look at population
health inside milwaukee and milwaukee
county
um i think i am going to go ahead
and continue on in my slides i can
definitely we could easily spend another
hour looking through all the data in
here but i think it'll be important to
kind of get through and show you a
couple other examples and some shiny
work and some
um our markdown and things like that
that we've done
but this was definitely um as i was
mentioning and when i was answering some
of the questions this was
really our first big shiny app as a data
science team
that we developed and so it was really
over the course of
after we did that initial factor
analysis it was kind of during the
course of 2018 that we worked on this so
it's
really came together well and it gave us
a foothold to kind of work with other
teams throughout the organization once
they saw this we had a data symposium
as an analytics team and we were able to
demo this and talk about the work we've
done
and it opened up a lot of doors across
the organization to partner with other
people so
one success kind of just rolls into the
next
implementation-wise these are some of
the packages that we used as we started
to build out
that application there's a lot of data
preparation
even with the data warehouse and the
cleaning and scrubbing we still had to
do
some probabilistic record matching
that's the fast link package
because there isn't a common id in that
that
statewide child welfare information
system we sometimes have to match on
name
and address or location so we'll do use
fast link for that
we do some graph manipulation obviously
with igraph and then we get statistics
off the graph with cina
things like that and then you saw some
other work
from the visual visualization side with
data table and high charter and leaflet
um shiny dashboard that that look and
feel of a dashboard that's kind of
of our adopted standard right now and
you'll see that in a couple examples
here in a couple minutes
behind kind of our analytic journey as
an analytics team
i report to our director of analytics
and so we this is our development as an
analytic team
i thought it was interesting to kind of
to lay this out and then also then
think about our growth of how we started
to use r during that
same time frame is when we started to
really bring
bring r along in the organization so it
started back in
2013 before we could even think about
using shiny or anything else i know
shiny was very in its early stages at
that
point um but it was really just a
limited number of people who kind of
brought it
forward and maybe evangelized it a
little in the organization
got some small wins or thinking oh that
looks cool that gg plot looks cool how
did you do that
and then we started to kind of grow that
um
at the same time you know our sas and
spss licenses come up for renewal we
start to think about well could we use r
for this
why wouldn't we use r for this or we see
something cool like the shiny app that
you'd think oh my gosh look at how you
can really
stand on the shoulders of giants as far
as all the packages that are available
and then we just kept it's kind of kept
snowballing to the point now where as we
start to look forward
um we think well is this a scriptable
first solution is this something we're
going to have to redo
and then um and we actually are bringing
along other analysts and our
analytics team to understand and be able
to use
r and apply it to the same request that
they would normally possibly use
excel or standard sql reporting tools
for as well
we you know push out office documents as
we need to
generating them with our markdown and
word or open xlsx
with and generating spreadsheets if we
need to and then schedule that all in
our studio connect
and push it out so we really have gotten
um
in this looking back it feels like it's
a short amount of time i know it's
probably six to eight years but um we
really have come a long way as far as
using our and i think the whole
community has as well
um just a quick snapshot i thought just
to kind of level set everyone where
where we're at
we have really at this point now in
2021 integrating ourselves into
the is environment so we're actually
using
our active directory for us for logging
in either to our studio workbench or to
connect our users use it
we use all the data warehouse and we
have the secure links so we don't have
to kind of sit to the side as we
were when we were first kind of doing
the prototypes and proof of concepts
we actually have a full-blown kind of
environment that's integrated in we
still have this is just for the data
science group we still use like tableau
and click view and things like that
ssrs for reporting as well as the line
of business
applications and their internal
reporting
but it feels like we're you know
equivalent to them in a lot of ways
where maybe at first when you're when
you're doing those prototypes
you're not um so just a quick background
on that
and then i thought i could maybe uh so a
couple more examples of some of the work
we've done
these will be um just some slides and
i'll talk through them a little bit
um the coveted ones everybody has a kova
dashboard i was joking yesterday with
rachel and shannon um and we were no
different right we were trying to get
all the information we could because
there wasn't really good information at
first i know johns hopkins and their
dashboard it became the standard the
gold standard people kind of lived by
um or went to and referred to but at the
early parts of it we were scraping the
same kind of data they were and trying
to get a picture of what's going on in
wisconsin
especially with kids because at that
point we didn't know what the impact
would be on kids
so we started to build out what i was
thinking was going to be
just a public or a population health
kind of dashboard once we started to
show this then
people became interested in adding in
internal information
so we wanted to look at other things
besides
just positive case rates and things like
that
so we started to think about what would
our what how else can we help across the
community
excuse me and across the children's
community the internal community
um and so a couple use cases popped up
during our response
including that dashboard i just saw the
screenshot for we also started to think
about
during lockdown we still had to serve
the kids who needed to had acute cases
or needed surgeries
so we wanted to make sure that they got
the care they needed and we had
a very very restricted list of people
who could come to campus so we generated
excel spreadsheets every day and pushed
them out to the people
these are things that we couldn't
quickly do on our ehr but we were able
to do that
using r and r studio and just kind of
push and create that spreadsheet
and kind of give them exactly what they
wanted you know instead of saying well
here's a report you can re
run from a reporting server we generated
and there's other ways to do this
certainly but
it kind of fit well with what we were
doing already within our studio connect
to extend that um same with surgical
cases
elective cases were being cancelled the
concern then became
are we are we sure all the kids who had
an elective case canceller getting
the care they needed you know at some
point did they reschedule
and so we started to think about how do
we track that recovery
and then we also were monitoring
patients being tested when they came to
campus they had to have a test
24 hours before and also employees as
they were working we were doing testing
for that too we wanted
to understand and inform our leadership
that this was occurring and that the
rates were low enough to feel
comfortable
and then we did a bunch of recovery work
also we had to update our
um you know our time series models and
we start to think about
how we were projecting um volumes to
come into different clinics and things
like that obviously the volumes crashed
during lockdown so we
um updated those models tried to try to
predict best we could because we didn't
know what the new environment was going
to look like
so that was some of the work that we did
and i'll show you a couple examples
here whoops
first is um some a little bit more this
is the dashboard
telehealth was a new thing for us also
we didn't have a lot of telehealth
presence
before um kova than the pandemic so we
started to monitor that
and we gave them a couple views of
interactive um
charting either with high charter here
or else ggplot just wrapped in plotly
and then we could kind of see you can
see the the
huge spike we had in telephone uh
encounters for instance right away
those stopped being reimbursed so they
dropped off but we could still continue
to monitor that
and then also um as you can see here on
the left hand side we also
also took a look at we've added
vaccinations now we looked at regions of
the state we looked at wisconsin as far
as in the north central u.s to look at
our borders because we didn't want to
limit it just
to some arbitrary geographic boundary
and to understand what was going on
in our environment
um testing this was a this is another
nice
ad we did we already had lab testing and
lab reporting but here we extended it
quickly with some existing gg plots and
then we just pushed it out with blastula
on our studio connect again informing
all of our
hospital leadership of the testing rates
again for patients as well as employees
here's an example of that surgical case
recovery email that was going out every
day at first it was very scary right we
were saying how many cases have been
canceled and how many have been
completed and you can see it was it
definitely took a while to tip back over
past 50 percent where in into late last
summer where we started to actually
start to recover that case work and make
sure that the kids were
had the surgery or had any kind of
procedure they needed
and had it performed and here again we
pushed out information by
service as well as at the bottom of this
email and this went to the entire
surgical services leadership so they
could say
well this service is performing well but
maybe gi for instance wasn't getting all
of their cases recovered that they
should have or they should have some
follow-up so we
would offer resources to help do that
follow-up and contact patients and their
families
and for this we used um again our
markdown blastula
pushing it from connect and we used um
this was one of the first uses of gt
that new table package which i think was
a
which is a real nice package to use for
creating tables if you're used to using
cable
and then finally we built another shiny
app um
again to kind of update and look at ways
we could think about modeling
what our response looks like this um
the black line you can see is kind of
that crash where orange is what we were
expecting for volumes
um black is kind of that true crash and
then we were trying to model what it
looked like
in the um in the days or months after
the pandemic
when we started to come out of lockdown
and we used external data so it was
interesting use of using like google
mobility data and apple you know we had
their mobile mobility data so we could
start to see movement acro
in milwaukee and southern wisconsin
southeastern wisconsin
we also got consumer spending data from
wompley
um and then job postings and
from burning glass i believe it was um
so we could look at
activity in the environment and try and
look for correlations to see if there's
any kind of
kind of variation we could tease out of
that to see if that maybe could help us
inform our models and so
it was kind of a short-term project
where we just started to look at what it
might be to look like recovery looks
like and will we get back to any kind of
level of normal
and then we actually sat with some of
the leaders from our ambulatory side
from our
outpatient side and inpatient and just
started to talk about
what we were seeing in the environment
because we knew the volumes were going
to be down across the board
uh how are we doing on time we're doing
okay rachel
yeah do we have more questions or we we
do have a few more questions
okay question break yeah i'd say one of
the most upvoted questions right now is
is more around the org structure of your
data science program
and how you've gotten buy-in to build r
into the analytics
infrastructure yeah that's a great
question and i i regret that i don't
have a slide on it i did think about
that yesterday after we reviewed these
um but so our uh i think the buy-in
um well two things i guess so yeah our
analytics team
we have kind of an analytics team back
in 2012
2013 we brought the majority of the
analysts together into an
enterprise analytics group so instead of
having them
dispersed among the departments within
children's we brought them together to
try
and understand it was at the same time
we were bringing in our new ehr
and so it was a perfect time to kind of
bring everybody together
get them all level set on data and data
sources
and then at some point we would maybe
spin them back out right
but um we used an analytic center of
excellence instead where we would reach
out to any kind of
power users maybe to help share that
load but most of the analysts still sit
within this
enterprise team and that's the team that
data science is part of
and so we have plenty of analysts
and then we have a two to three data
scientists including myself
who work on kind of these more strategic
or longer term projects
to get buy-in i think again i touched
something a little bit but i really
think it's those small wins
like where you can actually get in kind
of
deep dive learn all you can and then
produce something
that is like wow or or find some insight
and i know it's
hard to predict that that's always
possible
but i think we've been lucky and that
we've had some very curious
um counterparts on the business side of
the hospital that worked with us
to help us get that success and then
once we did
they wanted to share it right and so we
had um
we used the open source shiny server at
first
but then once we got to a point we
needed to be able to have that tied into
active directory and
share security because not everybody can
see every application or analysis we do
and that's where i think we started to
get that to hold to bring rn more fully
awesome and chris this might be a little
bit related to
the um buy-in question but the next most
upvoted question is
how did you decide when to use shiny um
as well as like r versus tableau or
other ui tools
yeah that's a a great question too i
think
um because i i always question that
myself right it's like how much do we
want to take on as a data science team
when i'm thinking about the program as a
whole because we need to
do these in an ongoing basis and we do
have bi developers who are specialized
in qlikview
um and so i think the choice usually
comes down to at first we'll do
mostly static and ad-hoc kind of
analysis and then we as we start to
see if there's going to be a maybe a
little bit longer term need
to have some interactivity will will
will bring in
shiny usually though it starts out with
maybe
our markdown maybe some interactive like
a flex dashboard
that's maybe a little lighter weight if
it's something that's truly line of
business
counts volumes things like that or we
have an existing click view app for will
push the
the work towards that side so that's
kind of our decision point i think
great thank you one more question
for now is um how open is data access
for your data science team within the
organization
um that is yes so our data science team
i definitely in even our analysts we
we are it's fairly open um we have
access just about everything we
we need or we can get access to um
we definitely have security on all those
different data sets but the data science
team
if we need some kind of access we
usually are able to get it so
it hasn't been an issue great
thanks chris yeah
so i'm gonna um spend maybe just five
more minutes talking about something
we're currently working on
um we're thinking about in the hospital
adding or kind of moving around some of
the units and
what kind of cohorts of patients they're
responsible for and this is coming out
of the need
for as we know there's um kind of a
mental health crisis maybe
coming our way um and it's certainly
true for children as well
um so we'd like to think about maybe do
we add a mental health
or behavioral health unit that you know
yeah at the hospital
for instance or do we partner or what do
we do um
and so they had a couple ideas about
what
maybe we could do with with um groups of
patients and placing them on different
units in the hospital but we didn't
really have a good way to say
all right well a we know that
outpatient volumes are increasing and
inpatient volumes are probably
decreasing a little it's a standard
trend
in health care
but we didn't know how what percentage
of maybe
a base year like to say we take 2019
volumes
and we think well what percentage of
2019 volumes will we
recover in 2021 because of the pandemic
and so we we gave we created a tool that
used kind of a monte carlo simulation
of different ways that we could look at
um
slicing up these volumes and we did it
by cohorts of kids and then we placed
cohorts of kids
on units and projected out a year
basically using the different parameters
that i was just
referring to as far as sampling
percentages we know that
let's just say 2019 volumes we know that
maybe we're going to see 90
of the volume we saw in 2019 and 2021 or
maybe 2021 and 2022
um but we know that that volume isn't
going to be exactly the same
um kinds of kids or is it all going to
be cardiac cases or just
you know going to be different kinds of
cases or or maybe broken bones or
or whatever so we wanted to try and
simulate a bunch of times just using
monte carlo of course
simulate a bunch of times and look at
what would be a a likely scenario
and then will it fit with our new
placement model
knowing that some of the beds are going
to be carved out for this new unit
so that's what this app was for and this
is one that's still ongoing because
we're working with
the hospital leadership to understand
the different models they're suggesting
and to see if it'll even make sense
from this looking at kind of historical
data and this modeling
so the very first step we did of course
was show them what's going on with the
hospital right
where do kids get admitted to where they
discharge from and we actually track
this more
granularly to look at all the units they
might stop and if they go to imaging or
lab
but we want to understand the movement
throughout the hospital
and this is just kind of a retrospective
look at that using plotly with the kind
in the sankey diagram here
at the same time we also looked at all
the historical data
and you'll see now it's just kind of an
interesting chart because we're showing
what we call tarp levels so if we get up
to like
17 or 18 here we go yellow that might
mean we might need to change staffing or
resource planning or we may
think about having to move kids to a
different um
unit possibly and this distribution here
is an
example of all the hourly census
um values that we've generated for the
hospital
so and we've done this by unit we did it
by service and we did it by kind of
cohort of kids
based on like diagnosis and attending
providers
and again so we're looking at how can we
find out what is a representative way to
look at
the populations before we ever talked
about doing any kind of simulation so
again this is a retrospective look
look at that and then we decided all
right now that we have all this data and
we have these distributions and we
understand
the distribution of kids and where they
fit let's kind of do this monte carlo
simulation right
and then project these cohorts going to
planned units and look at
kind of the activity map to say when are
we going to be at that red tarp level
where we know that we won't have enough
staff for enough
beds on for a given unit and then we can
kind of score the different units
and the different models to understand
that this model is going to fit or not
and here's your likelihood
and here is your confidence interval
saying this is what we think it might
look like for a given year and so we
have a couple
of different models created and then we
can kind of just run these scenarios
and so we've been helping them in this
kind of a
unique way i think of doing this
simulation just to understand
does this even make sense to suggest a
model like this
which is what we um ended up doing so
we're just currently in this we're
working on this right now
this is um kind of just like a work in
progress but i thought it was
interesting
that we started to apply like at first
we did origi the initial heat maps where
we just looked at volumes but it wasn't
a lot of meaning until we
applied that tarp level on top to say
yeah when it gets to be this dark it
actually is a red tarp and so we should
be concerned at the end of the year and
this is like flu season right
where it's starting to be worse um and
so we started to think about
um different ways to visualize that same
thing we actually went and also did it
instead of a heat map say how how green
is green and how red is red
and so we actually put that just across
a histogram like this so we could kind
of look at how deep into the red we were
going or how green we really were to
know if we had capacity
or if a unit could maybe take patients
from a different unit as we start to
think about
kind of pop-off units for
when we get to high-volume situations
um i think that was all i wanted to
cover with that right now
there's some definitely more work we did
some work on patient churn i think maybe
that would be a great
segue for another talk at a different
time but um we definitely are
using shiny heavily and this one is like
like i said one of the most
recent apps we've done and so a lot of
our learning has kind of
fallen into this one like we've kind of
switched over to plotly now for most of
our interactive charts away from high
charter i think the licensing is
a little nicer and the flexibility we're
getting with plotly where we can do the
sankey diagrams we can do these kind of
charts and we can
do a lot more um manipulation of what we
show and visualization
i did have just one final side probably
just talking about scoring and
measurement when we think about data
science
i'm always thinking about how to score
things or how to put things in context
for people and so we actually do look at
um scoring the individual units and then
providing a rolled up score for the
entire um facility
which is our milwaukee campus hospital
so we actually do that same kind of
level of scoring here
and then we actually will build up build
up some kind of report cards for the
different models that get suggested
okay i saved us five minutes for
questions
thank you so much chris that's an
amazing presentation and
awesome just to see all the different
ways that you're using r
um i know a lot of people would probably
love to be able to use
some of these shiny apps as well and fit
them to their own use cases
too so maybe in the future we'd be able
to
get something from github or yeah
um there's a few more questions that
we didn't get a chance to answer yet um
so if anybody has to leave
chris did say he'd be happy to answer
any other
questions in like a blog post or on our
healthcare slack channel
which shannon is going to share a little
bit more about
um but let's take time for two more
questions matt had asked how long does
it take to go from concept to production
for a project like this does the
engineering work occur before
or alongside your build yeah i would say
it's very iterative i mean the kovit app
we brought up within a week or two
because that could build on the other
dashboards so once we have something
scripted we kind of have these templates
or skeletal
apps that we can quickly pull something
together
we definitely are leveraging our great
uh analysts and our our data engineers
who
pull a lot of the data together for us
before we ever have to
work on a problem um so
the inpatient molly when i just showed
you that work it started for me
at the end of april um so really
that app came together and the
simulation and runs
um since april i mean so it i think we
it's very rapid
and i think that's that's the power of
our right and um it's like we just can
be so
iterative and and responsive um in a
short amount of time once you're
you know fluent in it of course
awesome so one more question before i
turn it over to
shannon to share the slack but um mara
had asked what type or amount of
clinician involvement
do you have on your team
um so we always yeah that's uh
hopefully i made that clear i mean for
sure i don't know all this stuff that
we definitely are partnering on every
step of the way we um
we have a cmio who works very closely
with analytics like i said
our enterprise analytics is not in the
is group we're outside of is
we're within our health management group
which is like a population health team
um similar to it uh and so then we have
actually have
um nurses rns on that team as well but
then
any kind of request that comes in we're
always working with providers side by
side
um which is so enjoyable i mean that's
one great thing about children's
um but it definitely yeah we give a lot
of involvement and that makes us
successful i think
which is also kind of a metric we use as
we start to look at new projects too
is how invested the business side is in
it before we go too far with it
thank you so much chris and and as i
mentioned if there any questions went
unanswered i'm going to send those over
to chris as well
so that we can share those with everyone
um but shannon i want you to be able to
share the slack
too i'm sorry i'll stop yeah so we um
have created an rn healthcare slack
channel so that you know the
conversation can continue
after this session and and beyond i know
that
there are a lot of great questions for
chris and i think some of those
questions might be
might be good topics for broader
discussion as well so please feel free
to join that slack group i'm gonna
put the link in the chat again um we're
also gonna be sending out a google form
if anyone wants to
uh suggest speakers or volunteer to
speak we'd love to do these more
regularly i think this was
an awesome talk and i'd love to see more
from from members of the community as
well
thank you shannon and i will
echo everything that shannon just said
we'd love to
to have these more regularly as well so
thank you all so much for joining and
thank you so much chris this was amazing
oh thank you very much thank you
[Music]
everyone
you